when I when I signed up for this I
didn't realize that I was going to be
following Terry which in terms of tough
acts to follow for this series it's
probably at the top of my list but I
still think it's going to be fun it's
good to be here I've certainly attended
many talks here in the past as as
Michael mentioned I did a master's in
HCI let's just say a few years ago and I
worked on with the intact Ares project
on collaborative workspaces it was
called actually interactive workspaces
with a room in the basement here and
also was influenced quite a bit by
Professor Pam Hines who still here in
the MS any department who studies
distributed work in teams especially
globally distributed teams and you'll
see bits of both of that in today's talk
so that's enough about me that was a
good introduction I want to tell you
about a guy named Dallas Dallas is an
electrical engineer he he was working a
few years ago Willow Garage as an
electrical engineer and he he faced a
dilemma his family was in Indiana but
his job was in California and until
recently the only solution was to choose
one or the other or waste a lot of time
and money flying back and forth so
Dallas chose his family he lives in
indiana and he used he continued to work
for well using sort of the traditional
teleconferencing options that are
available today video chat search you
know remote collaboration tools but he
felt like over time his sense of
presence was starting to attenuate he
felt like his connection to his
colleagues was weakening he missed
informal gatherings he felt like he was
out of the loop on some things I know
people would forget to ask him questions
they would forget to keep him in the
loop so yeah so in short he was losing a
sense of presence and luckily he was
working at a place that had a lot of
things he could put together a solution
and with one of his co-workers their guy
named Kurt Myers he put together
prototype for remote presence which was
called Tex i Tex I seemed pretty cool a
lot more people got involved with the
project at that point including myself
and we went through many rounds and
prototyping and user study I'm going to
skip over most of that but we took
everything we learned there and we
applied applied it to be actually i'll
come back to it later in the talk as i
go through our research so being watched
last fall from our company suitable
technologies we believe it's the best
remote presence device that you can buy
and for dallas what this does is this
technology
gives back his sense of presence you
know now he can hang out at a desk so
people can drop by and asking questions
whenever they want to he can follow
people out of a meeting continuing the
discussion he can find people to talk in
person sometimes when they don't want to
be found and you can see things from all
angles he's not just stuck on a wall
he's not stuck on a desk he can move
around he can see things from all angles
as if he were there in person and he has
a great quote he says living in indiana
and working in silicon valley with beam
is isn't the best of both worlds it is
both worlds and this is really how he
sees it so what I'd like to do today is
review some research on remote presence
even if it wasn't called that yet when
the research was being done talk about
why we designed being the way we did the
research that we've done since we've
built beam and then where we see the
research going in the future and some of
the open questions that we think are
really interesting right now so I think
to really give you a quick overview of
the beam product I would show our
product video I didn't want to include
the sound so I didn't bother to hook it
up but i just wanted for people who
haven't seen this if you've ever been to
our website you've probably seen this
video already so one quick note on
terminology we refer to the person
operating the device as a pilot so in
this video this woman Susan is the pilot
and everyone else is a local the people
who are interacting with her through the
device we refer to them as locals so
being really consists of three pieces
the remote presence device itself this
dock which is for charging and then the
software that the pilot installs on
their computer in order to control and
use the system and you'll see examples
of all this through the through the
video some other stats it has a 17 inch
LCD display it's 5 feet 2 inches taller
158 centimeters has two HD cameras you
can see other stacked to give you a view
of both in front and below microphone
array above the screen speaker below to
Wi-Fi radios and top speed of 1.5 meters
per second or about a little over three
miles per hour
so this is the punch line at the end of
this video is that it turns out she was
home the whole time traveling around the
world working with her team in Asia
America and everything and but she was
actually comfortably at home in her own
office so if you want to see that video
again it's at suitable tech comm the
benefits of working remotely also
sometimes called teleworking or
telecommuting are pretty well documented
I think at this point there was a some
research came out of Stanford actually
in Economics Department last year
Nicholas bloom did the largest most
empirical study yet on this topic with
the Chinese travel agency called travel
agency called see trip where they did an
experimental where they grouped the
workers into people who are able to work
at home and those who had to come into
the office and found you know outside
the margin of error that people were not
only more productive and half year but
also healthier when they were able to
work at home and that was you know so
and that was in terms of reduced number
of sick days so it's like a win-win-win
and it means you can live anywhere you
can cut down and travel another cost so
why doesn't everyone work from home if
that if it's so great well there are
several reasons some of the most
commonly cited are things like some
tasks are difficult to do this way you
know to be honest sometimes you need you
know to be able to use your thumbs or
other things that are hard to do
remotely with technology available today
sometimes there's a stigma or a
suspicion of not working as hard when
you're at home depends on the company
culture and one of the most commonly
cited things is the importance of
face-to-face communication and the
reason I have picture of Yahoo after
many of you may have you know heard
about there was some news earlier this
year where they basically put a total
ban on any kind of remote working inside
the company and that was one of the
things that was cited in their internal
memo the importance of face-to-face
communication so that's why remote
presence is so exciting to us and I
think it's a really transformative
technology because you can get all these
Bennett's of benefits of being able to
work remotely you know being happier
being more productive of being able to
have more control over your time and
where you live but also still preserve
the rich face-to-face interaction that
is so important to
people have pondered the possibilities
of remote presence for centuries and
perhaps longer so I'm going to do like
400 years of philosophy in two minutes
so starting with Descartes for example
who had this concept of an evil demon
with the power to intercept your senses
and present arbitrary information to you
to basically trick you into thinking
there's a world an alternate world is
that's not the one that actually exists
this is similar to the brain in a vat
thought experiment famous one in
philosophy they're both basically a
man-in-the-middle attack on your brain
saying you don't know if your if your
brains in a body or if it's in a jar
somewhere hooked up to some sensors and
some stimuli it but they but they both
raise the question of what it actually
means to believe you're anywhere and in
some sense the reason I bringing
ourselves in substance what we're trying
to do with remote presence is attempt to
provide enough sensory information to
your brain to make you think that you
are somewhere else at least to some
degree maybe for the purposes of the
work that you're trying to do also I
wanted to mention of phenomenologist
such as Heidegger encouraged us to see
the difference between perceiving
objects as they actually are and the
purpose in perceiving them as fulfilling
a purpose so in the language of
Heidegger we want remote presence to be
already ready to hand technology not
present at hand you don't want to see a
remote presence device and just see it
as a collection of components and pieces
of technology you want to see what it's
for which is actually transporting you
or transporting someone else from one
place to another and finally I wanted to
mention the the blind man by man's cane
example from merleau-ponty which is
suggested that you know when a blind man
finding his way through the world by
using a cane he's not so much feeling
the wood of the cane you know the wood
grain and the specific makeup of what
the cow the cane is composed what he's
feeling the world through the cane in a
very similar way we want people to
experience the world through a remote
presence device so we need to replicate
we need to reproduce that as faithfully
as we can Erving Goffman's book from
1959 the presentation of self and
everyday life tremendously influential
book in computer-mediated communication
and remote presences is definitely no
exception goffman suggest that all
social interaction is a performance so
in every interaction that you have
in life you're trying to present
yourself in the way that you want others
to perceive you and this applies as I
said all kinds of interactions but
perhaps none more literally than remote
presence because you're little you you
are literally on camera while you're
using it and so if you're using this
kind of technology all day long you know
a pilot station is kind of like a MIDI
TV studio since this is the way people
are going to perceive you you start to
care about things like how's my lighting
what's the acoustic property of the room
i'm in how's my camera how's my camera
positioned do i have good microphones
and stuff that you don't really have to
normally have to worry about in person
but you're much more conscious of this
if you use remote presence so in the
1980s researchers started building
systems that more closely resemble the
kind of remote presence technology that
we see today the media spaces project at
xerox parc for example created a
connection between the lab in palo alto
in and another one in portland using
real-time audio and video and these
projects saw really saw the importance
of informal communication between team
members and and saw many similar uses
that we seen with remote presence in and
with being today such as impromptu
conversations being able to find people
as I mentioned this was very important
for Dallas creating more informal
awareness of each other and then going
forward a few years there was a paper
from how an in-store neta called beyond
being there that I believe was really
ahead of its time and it's it's
interesting because it's a difficult one
for people like me as a technology
enthusiast to really read and appreciate
because what they say and what they
really prove in the paper is that remote
people will always be at a disadvantage
with the kind of technology that we have
no matter how faithfully reproduces the
experience unless it's good enough that
people who are local also have a benefit
for using it so that's why it's that's
why the paper is called beyond being
there it's not just being there it's
actually you need to go beyond that you
need to look for needs that are not
being met in physical proximity and
focus on those and I'll come back to
this a little bit with our research on
beam I also wanted to mention the the
olsens Judith and Gary Olson wrote on
this team several years later showing
that new technology hasn't actually
improved distance work as much as
everyone thinks it has
and they describe something called
tightly coupled work which is work that
requires a lot of frequent communication
has a lot of ambiguity and show that
remote technologies don't support most
of the features that are so important to
this type of work and there are several
things that they list but you know uh
you know some of the most important are
shared local context between
collaborators having informal time
having individual control with the
current technology that really doesn't
exist nonetheless in the early part of
the last decade people started to
prototype these kinds of systems as the
as the technology started to support it
more and more on the far left you see
something called proper personal roving
presence from john canyon or call us at
berkeley they even tried blimps so with
the giant eyeball use and then by
reality was a project to HP labs from
norm juvies lab which was a highly
immersive take on remote presence this
is the pilot room that you see here is
kind of a wraparound screen they really
spared no expense and it was it was
really interesting system at that time
and of course we're not the only ones
working on this today as well this this
team at Microsoft Research for example
has built something they call the
embedded social proxy which is very
similar to a beam except that you can't
drive it and it's targeted at the hub
and satellite kind of team namely one
person is remote from the rest of the
people in a local site and they found
some results that are actually really
similar to what we've seen with beam
such as stronger social connections
increased attention and affinity and
increased participation in meetings and
they've published some of this work you
can read some of their findings so with
that is background before I go any
further I'd like to present our
definition of remote presence it's kind
of a new term it's really not
telepresence is not robotics it's
something different royal presence
refers to a system or device that
enables people separated by distance to
collaborate communicate and understand
each other as if they shared the same
physical space without losing
effectiveness over time and that last
part is really really important in to
put it another way it's something that
you can rely on every day you can rely
on it to do your job yeah sure
for more presents all of these things so
I was just going to give some some
examples of things that are similar to
remote presence some people might think
of them that way so for example audio
conferencing is a is a very valuable
tool and enables more collaborative
meetings but you know you don't you
don't have it's easy to be forgotten
when you can't be seen so this is the
only way that you're interacting with
your team you know over time you know
there are going to be meetings where you
get something something gets brought up
and they free to ask you about it or
they forget that you're on the phone and
sort of that level of frustration that's
what we've seen with our research and
some of these other ones that's why you
know you see the olsens sighting of
those those factors of a tightly coupled
work that just that frustration builds
over time and it's just not good enough
for what you're using it for all sorry
so the other thing about losing
effectiveness over time is you know for
example the text I system that we built
at Willow Garage was functionally very
similar to what we've done machine but
it only worked ninety-five percent of
the time versus theme no 99 percent plus
and so at the time we didn't understand
the importance of that difference and it
was only once we started putting it into
field sites and trying to get people to
incorporate that into their normal work
day that we discovered that it just it
wasn't good enough you'll you only have
to miss one important meeting for
technical reasons before you will stop
the lying on the technology that caused
you to step so seems like maybe or
you're pointing something out
embeddedness or infrastructure ready to
handedness that you're talking about
then something up over time that's oh I
guess I think they're related I'm not
sure I mean it's just you know if you
look at all the other the options that
have been set up in prototype that have
been put out there the reason I wanted
to bring this up is because our system
is if you just do sort of point by point
you know the components that it has okay
it has video as audio Wi-Fi roaming
whatever it's actually not that
different but but the amount of
engineering that is gone to take all
those that heterogeneous system and make
the whole thing work together reliably
every time it's been a tremendous amount
of work and and it's really important
for this reason and so you know when we
put text I in the field we
confused why are not people why aren't
people using is it does everything that
they think it does but it was just
little stuff like you know it would roll
off the charger once a week or once a
month even or they couldn't connect you
know for some crazy reason every now and
then and and then before long they were
all just sitting darken in the corner I
was just going to mention a skype on a
laptop is another kind of remote
presence that you see more and more it's
mobile but it requires assistance that's
a big drawback and then cisco
telepresence is beautiful its lifelike
quality but it has a big problem that
it's stuck in one place so here a couple
snapshots of our office incorporating
remote presence so it's pretty much like
any other office you know we sit around
we talk to each other we have meetings
you know but you can sort of substitute
beams or people in beams for people
being in person and it the interesting
thing about it to meet well there are
many interesting things one of your
thinking about it is when I go to the
office in the morning I actually don't
know who's going to be there in person
beat most of the people you see here
actually live locally so you know we we
force ourselves to use the device to
understand how it works if you don't
force yourself to use it's too easy to
circumvent when you want to and then you
don't understand the true experience of
being a remote person so when I go into
the office in the morn I don't know
who's going to be there and who's going
to be in a beam but it doesn't make any
difference and that is the real goal is
that it can be the same whether you're
there in person or whether you're there
in a remote presence device now I want
to quickly mention no Hollywood always
has with these uncanny predictions for
new technology I'd say what we're trying
to do is build version 0.001 of what you
see an average are there been some other
movies that have had takes on remote
presence i think are interesting to with
avatar is like you know if you go way
out into the future that is that is
really remote presence we're a long way
from that and then there's this
Hollywood interpretation I feel
obligated to bring up because anytime
there's a story about being or any kind
of remote presence device the number one
comment on the Internet is something
along the lines of they stole this from
Sheldon on the big bang theory which is
a CBS sitcom the truth is not only did
they not steal from us are we still from
them they use text I to film the show
and it was really fun and the thing that
surprised me the most about it is that
they didn't they didn't even want to
fake the system they just used a live
running tech side so 95% was good enough
to film a TV show
but to use it every day in your life you
know it has to be even more reliable so
this is kind of what I was getting too
before so the difference between these
systems really is engineering you know
functionally there's not that much
difference you've got video you've got a
head that you can see it's real-time the
audio is pretty good but the difference
here is that this is designed to be
reliable consistent and cheaper to
produce and this is but I think this is
a really really important difference for
HCI an HR I research because it takes
this technology from being something
that you can test in a lab in a
controlled setting with small number of
people to something you can test with
almost anyone in the world it has an
internet connection and that's the kind
of research that we're doing now and
we're getting some results that I think
really interesting so I'm going to share
that so we've done with as I mentioned
we've also set up company policies to
force ourselves to use this technology
to try to get a better idea internally
what it's like to be a remote person who
has to rely on this every day with our
customers we've we've done basic field
work mostly interviews we've studied a
total of twenty-four users across three
continents highlighted on the map with a
combination of 30 to 60 minute
interviews and other informal
observations some of the cut some of the
users are us somewhere from our early
customers some use the device a few
times a week some use it all day long
every day so to try to make the the
results of a little more concise we've
come up with what we believe are six
core principles of what it takes to have
remote presence and initially our rule
of thumb was we want to be able to do
what a human can do we want to reproduce
that as reliably as possible but you
know as I said earlier we've learned
through this research and maybe we would
have learned if we'd surveyed the
literature a little bit more upfront
that actually we do need to go beyond
being there in some important ways and
I'll go through each of these in turn
okay so humans can move freely in all
directions you can keep up with other
people as they're walking you're not
going to be stymied by a pencil on the
floor or even furniture that's in your
way you can push it out of your way so
if you're going to have a remote
presence it's important to be able to do
the same thing this is just a quick
demonstration of some of the physical
capabilities of a beam you can push
chairs you
over wires you can push doors open and
close on the lighter side of things we
recently converted one of our one of our
offices into a makeshift soccer field
using beam we call it bean ball it's
pretty fun but in general wherever
wherever people can go beam can go and
also you'll probably notice I use the
term beam interchangeably with remote
presence device I apologize it's been
wrapped up in this world for so long a
lot of times what I mean to say is this
applies to remote presence devices but
you know that's been that's been my
focus for so long it's hard for me to
some ties separate the two but another
part of being able to move freely as
having a UI that makes it intuitive to
do so if you're struggling with the
device and it's not going to feel like
you have the kind of freedom to move
that you want so we went through several
iterations on this ultimately settled on
this layout because it it allows you to
us to stack the video so you've got the
vertical continuity between the two
cameras but also makes the videos as
large as possible so you've got the
highest resolution what you can see and
have and have the controls to to move
the device around and we're still
working on it of course but this is the
best we've done so far having to ask
people for help is is really an
impediment to feeling remotely present
it makes you dependent on them so for
example it's very important that you can
dock yourself this is something that we
learned with Tex I in the early days of
beam you know for example Dallas any
time he was done using the device he had
to ask someone to go plug him in and
that got to be very frustrating and in
least one of those things that like in
tort in terms of being able to use it
over time without losing effectiveness
that kind of thing that frustration
builds up and you just say I'm tired of
it and I don't to use it anymore so we
have to solve all of those problems and
some of the other remote presents you
might have seen also have this problem
another sort of on the other side you
also don't want anyone to have to help
you to get into the device you can just
log in and go and this is again this is
what we mean by having self-sufficiency
you don't have to have anyone except the
call for you set up the system add you
to an address list anything like that
because we found it really one of the
most important things about having
effective remote presence says no one
else needs to learn any new behavior to
interact with you they can just talk to
you like yeah oh sorry target Terry I
thought you had a question actually
that's interesting so your ability to do
this I'll come back to that later
because that's the kind of thing that
you know our users are asking for
nonverbal communication things be able
to do things without having to create
attention so yeah so the idea is that
you can interact with somebody using the
device the same way that you would
interact with a human and then one one
last example I wanted to give up
self-sufficiency so P pilots often mute
their microphones for a variety of
reasons maybe you've got kids screaming
in the background and that's good but
they often forget to unmute before they
start speaking again and that's very
frustrating because you know you have to
rewind the first five seconds of every
conversation when this happens and so we
tried and it's also a mistake you would
never make in person so again does these
are the things that add up so we tried a
bunch of things but found that one small
change really made a big difference and
unfortunally don't have a video of it
here but what happens what the system
does is if it detects your speaking
while it's muted it will pulse that that
that mute message with your input audio
level so basically if you start talking
and you're muted this thing will start
to flick a red give you an indication
that hey you're talking but no one's
hearing you and that is almost entirely
resolved this problem now people stop
complaining about this so much and we're
really excited that that made such a big
difference I mean you don't want to walk
around feeling like you're looking
through a tube right so if that's what
it feels like to use remote presence
again it will be frustrating peripheral
awareness is very important but so is
the ability to zoom in on things and so
you know that's why we chose these wide
angle lenses to be able to give you the
peripheral awareness but also coupled
that with the ability to zoom in on
details so we have a digital zoom that
you can use because we want to give you
a field of view that is pretty close to
human and kind of this the same thing
goes with audio you know you want to be
able to hear what's going on around you
not just when someone's speaking
directly in front of you so as I
mentioned earlier we built a microphone
array into the top and it has some
customs
to do background noise reduction and
echo cancellation and this is one of the
things where we were able to i believe
really get into beyond being there this
this is one area where it can truly be
better than being there in person and
i'll give you an example we have a
server closet like many companies full
of very noisy computers fans you know
etc they make a lot of noise if you go
in there you know it's almost it's
almost deafening and so if you build it
in there with another person you have to
scream to each other to be heard but if
you go in there in a beam its able to
effectively remove almost all of that
noise so what happens is if and I've
seen this happen otherwise I would have
never guessed two people are in the
server room with somebody in a beam
they're screaming to each other to be
heard but the beam pilot all he hears is
screaming people because it's removed
all the background noise and so in order
to hear each other they have to scream
but to him it's totally unnecessary so
you know this is one where if I had a
choice I would prefer to go into that
server room in a beam then going to the
quick yeah actually you have a lot of
all mostly Michael proprioception and in
this case with the weight represents
itself is that I I start speaking in my
volume is quite loud I'm not aware of
this do you run into these kinds of
awareness issues as well it's one of our
biggest problems and I will come back to
that later but so all you have is a
visual indication of how loud you are
and of course that changes depending on
the room you're into like if it's a
quiet room and then you go to a loud
room you know how do you know how much
you're supposed to change that or how
much do you know how much how do you
know how much to raise your mic gain
that's it that's a really big problem
for us in it and you really see it
exacerbated in situations where there
are multiple remote presence devices
because if there's one person being a
little too loud in a beam people will
compensate and just speak a little bit
louder back to that purse back to the
pilot but if you have a lot of people in
a room all doing that and then the beams
are sort of trying to one-up each other
it can become very loud quite quickly
it's kind of like the cocktail party
effect but for people who are maybe
don't have a good sense of how loud they
are so it's even worse I sorry not the
cocktail party effect I figure what this
is called but there's there is a there's
a property of conversation where people
will continually speak a little bit
louder than
other people in a room where a lot of
people are speaking so that they can be
heard and people will it's sort of like
uh there's like a game theory thing that
happens where people get louder and
louder and louder to the point where it
becomes painful and that's where it
stops so that's why anytime you go into
a room like like a cocktail party where
a lot of people are speaking it you know
it's at this level that's borderline
painful on your ears and so if everyone
could just voluntarily bring that down
it would solve the problem but anyway we
see the same thing with some with beam
and one other thing I wanted to mention
about audio is that audio for the locals
is also very good and I don't know if he
will believe me but this really does
happen there are times in our office
when you will go looking for somebody
because you heard them speaking and find
out that they're not actually there
they're just they're in a beam your
trick because you thought it just
sounded like they were there right say
you know hey so-and-so I you know can
you come help you with this and you said
wait a second I thought you were here
well I am here of course but I'm in a
beam and and if it weren't that good
then you would definitely wouldn't have
scenes like this because you know if we
couldn't faithfully reproduce the audio
it just wouldn't be good enough to go
you know analog-to-digital twice like
this and sure these folks could switch
to a multi-way video call or you know
Google hangout or something but this was
an impromptu discussion that would have
never happened if they weren't all
logged into a beam already and that's
kind of the important distinction here
the anchor says hi you Josh off in Syria
what is happening today the battle and
then you stand there looking stupid for
a few seconds buddies and there's you I
really feel it it's not yours thinking
if you haven't heard yet because I lag
do you get that phenomenon of lag with
these but we've got everything we can to
minimize the latency in our system but
network latency is something that you
know we have very little control over so
we generally speaking anywhere in North
America or two to Europe which is the
bulk of where we tried these things so
far it's been it's been good enough to
have a conversation I mean there's
research on how much latency you can
tolerate to have a conversation 400
milliseconds is like the upper bound of
where it becomes really just untenable
and so we've done everything we can to
live doing demise latency and our
Hardware in our software
but when you add that to the network
latency so India for example is kind of
pushing the limits of what we can do
from from North America to India the
network latency is just high enough that
we can't be certain about so we try to
control the situations where people are
using the device and if you're going
over a satellite link for example it
just wouldn't be I mean you could have a
conversation because you can learn how
to adjust that but but controlling a
hundred pound of remote presence device
you know in an environment with other
people that's not something that we're
comfortable doing so we actually have
safety limitations on that detect the
round-trip latency and won't let you
drive if it rises above a certain level
I routinely drak with someone who's
coming in through from Argentina and the
sound is perfectly fine I mean we have
normal conversations the only thing you
sometimes see is a little ghosting when
when she makes fast movements but no one
Argentina is a waste ways wedding stuff
and that probably has more to do with
the quality of the connections and
actually see all those things can be
related in a loss can cause latency and
vice versa yes hi Sherman cisco
telepresence I know what about name
seeker so we actually do have
conversation jquery in the world and I'm
to normal sentence to it well that one
way or roundtrip it's from one to the
other ok so yes when I said 400 I was
not around look well you have to pay
part so it isn't it isn't just over the
you know comcast network right hey Cisco
right so you know in terms of speed of
light from here the Indy I think it's
you know it's much more asleep it's more
like an order of 30 to 50 milliseconds
or something I can hook I mean you can
do the mail I I don't remember basically
if you pay enough money and say fiber
already you know no no subway thanks for
anything you can get so you see really
possible anywhere on earth to have a low
in a plane see connection if you have
the but most people who are trying these
devices out want to just use them over
the internet and sort of you know so
they don't have access to that kind of
thing but
ok the next remote presence principle I
wanted to talk about was the size of the
device so we experimented a lot with the
height we settle on and play 2 by 5 feet
2 inches because it's comfortable for
both standing and sitting interaction
and people always ask Oh have you
thought about making the head go up and
down yes we thought about it it adds a
lot of cost and complexity to
manufacturing and we thought that this
this height actually works pretty well
for both and Leila Takayama i think was
mentioned earlier here who's that of
researcher at Willow Garage has
collaborated with on a number of remote
presence questions but in specific
specifically she did a study with some
researchers from the University of
Wisconsin on the height of her mo
presence devices and found that indeed
it does have an attack on things like
leadership Authority and persuasiveness
interaction so it's really important to
get the height right and we we try we
believe we've done that but it I guess
the bigger point is it does matter so
it's a really interesting question some
people students research showed that you
know if it was looking down on you you
basically we're more submissive but it
if you were looking up at it was looking
up at you then odd even especially
getting the person on the other side of
the screen may not be aware where they
are right excuse might be leading to and
52 is really high because it means that
you're always one or the other right if
I'm just sitting I'm definitely looking
up and if I'm standing I'm almost very
certain we're looking down I'll send a
very short individual that's a good
point I don't know if we've studied the
difference between sitting and standing
interactions with respect I that is a
really interesting question yes hi
photos so we can beam control rate like
up and down sergeant Lee Desai could
also have been control rate she means to
be able to adjust the height yeah yeah
yeah but I was saying that we decided
against that for cost and complexity
reason so you're suggesting when you get
angry users but that's an interesting
social question how alcohol should you
be you know should you be allowed to be
whatever height you want you know
because what you're saying oh I'm gonna
go into a negotiation I want to raise it
up I should you be allowed to do that I
don't really know that's a good question
there's your V on being there yeah
that's so maybe you have to pay for it
actually at we were in South by
Southwest and uh no payment well you
probably don't follow this closely but
Shaq Shaquille O'Neal became very
interested he wanted to actually put
some money into our company and we were
kind of debating what kind of theme do
we need to build him because 52 is
probably not what he has a night but you
also some control the size of your face
by its topless you guessed correct in
another world at the convention beside
of the way we were 10 17 inches because
we felt like that was done the smallest
that we could get away with and still
show a head have relatively light like
size depending again how you positioned
it and we did experiments on this I
don't think it was everything it's ever
been published but Lela and some other
people did research also on the size of
the head of the remote presence device
and found that if you get larger then
life like it becomes creepy very quickly
so you could physically go along with an
even bigger screen that makes your head
even bigger and as soon as it's bigger
than life life-sized games I would
recommend against it yes so you said uh
mrs. Logan before you just mention it
again now um okay my initial thought for
like the issue of nonverbals is why I
have a full rectangle screen that shows
the full line right and like you know so
much of the nonverbal is that like what
this person's doing with our hands hello
you know so much nonchalant not like
conversation that got my shoes say like
that way that's being lost and you can't
like you know I'm fish my hands or not
image URL that's an interesting question
where would you put the camera though to
get that either you probably hating me
to three smaller cameras and right
because normally people are using it at
a desk you know it's like a desk like
this with a chair and a computer in
front so there's really no way to see
all of you so you'd have to sort of
build a custom station that you would
stand in front of it maybe I don't know
I mean yeah it's interesting question I
mean this actually walking around the
office then and they should be priced
and up anyway yeah the walking where
they're sitting or no they could be
doing a lot of things
my first reaction was like I would
probably make full screen because I want
to know like you know then he lose a lot
of the detail of the face so to get
facial you know there's a lot of
information conveyed claim no facial
reactions and things too so I was just
going to say that the the mechanical
design of our device the product design
of it was really dictated a lot of it
what by the fact that we wanted to have
this large display high off the ground
but still be dynamically and statically
stable so if you think about okay why
why does the device look the way it does
a lot of it is just to be able to put
that screen up there and make the things
still safe and stable to be around so we
talked about this a little bit already I
made the point that you know even if it
worked ninety-five percent of the time
like for example if your car worked
ninety-five percent of the time you
might stop using it to get to work you
just can't afford the risk that one out
of every twenty times you're not gonna
be able to go to work today because your
car stopped working so that's where
we're trying you know that's why we're
trying to get with this you know
ninety-five percent is good for
prototypes it's good for experimentation
but it's not good enough to build a
product that people are going to make
part of their of their normal work
practice you know along the lines of a
plain old telephone or say a toyota
camry that's that's what we're really
going for here with this product you
just you know it will work whenever you
need it okay so just to recap these were
our Royal presence principles you know
you can move freely your self sufficient
you have good audio audio and visual
awareness you're roughly the human size
or at least when it's appropriate and
you can count on it you can count on the
device when you need it so let's see ok
so we learned some interesting stuff in
addition to this sort of the overall
principles of what it means to have
remote presence we've learned some
surprising things some some have been
good some have been surprising and I'll
get to both of them we did indeed find
that people felt like they had more
presence here are some quotes from from
actual bean pilots I really call
attention to the last two especially
this this last one this is a guy who is
separated by his colleagues from his
colleagues by an ocean and nine time
zones and when is the last time that you
saw someone high five a video
conferencing display I thought that was
really cool and it kind of shows how
it's making him more human to his
coworkers
sort of continuing on the idea of being
more human we see that people are able
to interact in more sophisticated ways
with this last quote you can see that
sometimes it's the absence of something
that shows you its value this was
somebody who'd come to rely on beam and
then lost it for a day because of a
networking issue I think he was moving
or something like that and so he said
without it he just felt blind he just
felt like he didn't have the kind of
awareness that he was used to and
another thing that we see is that
experienced pilots learn how to make
more natural movements taking advantage
of the mobility that the device gets
them so you'll see in this example the
pilots following the conversation which
you know but gives you a much better
idea of where his intent whereas
attention is you can move forward just
to signal the increased attention or or
you can move back just for the opposite
and even if you're not following a
conversation you know the most
experienced pilots will still kind of
move themselves around a little bit just
to show that they're alive and it's
really interesting and it really adds to
the feeling that they're there we saw
concrete examples of how communication
improved people are able to do things
like pair programming we didn't
necessarily expect that it would work
for that this is something that I would
love to say we empirically also can
prove but we really can't this is more
anecdotal but you know in our use years
of using rural presence even going back
before beam we found that it takes about
20 minutes for a local to forget that
they're talking to a person through a
device and they just think they're
talking to a person and we know this
from The Times is something happens to
break the spell like a technical glitch
or some kind of other interruption or or
the guy asked you know the pilot has to
leave and you sort of startled back into
reality wait a second I thought this
person I was talking to his here they're
not really well they're kind of here I
don't know so that's really cool it so
it gives us a also a good idea of how
long a demo we need to do if we're
trying to sell one of these and we'd
love to get this number down to zero of
course but knowing what the number is
now actually is pretty valuable okay so
can you have too much presence being in
a remote presence device makes you very
conspicuous some people like this some
people don't kind of depends on your
personality I think it'll be really
interesting to see how this evolves as
they as the devices themselves
themselves become more common and more
ubiquitous it's less of a of a curiosity
and
is there something about the device it
still makes it kind of stand out full
screen someone over skype we're there
I'm screen like God god mode right there
they're knitting is basically everyone's
focal point even if you're giving I said
even if you're speaking it's at least
constrained to the screen yeah that's an
interesting comment I mean so in this
particular example there was a person
who was knitting momentum P to sort of
sit participating in the back of meeting
not really no getting any attention and
so but people just because of being in
the beam that that person got a lot of
attention and clearly didn't intend for
it but I see yeah I mean this is I would
say that's another limitation of using
this for remote presence it's like
making them even less human right a lot
of these questions are at kind of along
that lines of the not only not only
because it's new but also because we're
able it's suitable we have a much higher
proportion of we have a higher
saturation of remote presence devices
than probably almost anywhere else in
the world and so we're seeing things
that maybe are the tip of the iceberg or
maybe are just really unique to to the
kind of environment that we have yes
when you have dinner face up on your
computer can you also be multitasking
and doing other things oh and just okay
is that I imagine that is not quite the
same thing as knitting but might have
some similar characteristics I mean it
depends on yes it would to me it's one
of the it's one of the things that does
make it better than being there too
because it would be difficult in many
meetings to be doing something
simultaneously that wouldn't be
considered either rude or for
distracting depending what else you're
trying to do ameya do chicken email on
the laptop it's okay but so it gives you
the ability to really be doing two
things at once if you want to again it
kind of depends on through the culture
place that you're in and the people you
work with think of a kind of a both ways
we use so it's suitable we do a lot of
passive evening we just kind of sit and
log in and sit at our desks and you know
that that creates all that informal
aware
impossible stuff that we think is so
great most of the most of our early
customers have not adopted that same
behavior and it could just simply be
because they don't have the same number
of devices that we have or maybe there's
something about it it just doesn't quite
click for them this is something we
really need to understand we were
expecting more of that because we think
it's really valuable so we need to
understand why more people aren't
adopting the same the same behavior this
is again this is something that's unique
because as I said no one else has so
many devices at least per person but our
company of 20 people regularly has seven
or eight people in a beam at one time
I've seen as many as 10 and so I'm
showing this picture because it gives
you an idea to what it's like to be the
only human in a meeting full of remote
presence devices and he's he's smiling
but some people again it depends on your
personality some people can be
uncomfortable by this the things that
make it not quite human they start to
they start to add up I think there's
some kind of additive effect that's
happening here so like for example the
fact that you can't tell who a pilot is
from all sides you can see if you're
looking at the front at the screen but
from the side or if you get a funny
angle then you can't tell me so all
those think those little things when
there's a lot of them I think it starts
to add up and makes it yes the
interaction a little less than being
there would you say oh it wasn't if I'm
looking at another pilot you know and
there's some boxes I guess you know from
looking at them and you know are you is
that a challenging scenario it's not
yeah I mean it's not as good as seeing
them with your eyes in person but it's
good enough that works I mean we do this
it doesn't stop us from doing this mr.
black most the beam level oh is it an
ego may be hitting it he had to turn
yeah and then she sort of happy but you
turn you know you're probably pretty
laughter in the meeting and then you you
remember where people are right so you
kind of established whose we're at the
start of the meeting I think you know
people look around and see what's going
on and then you probably remember Sue's
to his left but you can't tell by
looking at all times now that's exactly
what I'm talking about and so and I also
think there's this thing happening where
the more more devices that are there at
the same time the more used
to see them as devices again instead of
people and again this is something we
need to improve and looking for another
side is a similar picture this is what
it's like to be actually to be the only
human and the reason I wanted to show
this one is you can see how they're kind
of all circled around I don't know why
this is happening again this is stuff
that we need to understand but when
you're the only human with a lot of with
a lot of beams or remote presence
devices they kind of they all end up
looking at you somehow there's like
you're a human anchor for this
interaction and if they start talking to
each other they'll turn but then they
always kind of come back to looking at
the person who's in the room or the
people and and of course in it at some
point it can start to be like why am I
here you know what what do I need to be
here for did I just turn the lights on
you know that kind of stuff these are
good problems to have by the way if the
problems we have that are too many
devices out of the world and we're
excited about that but and this is
something we talked about already it's a
little harder to know how loud you are
so it can get loud this is I think this
is really interesting so there's this
tension between being able to go beyond
being there but also giving people
superhuman powers that are going to make
the locals uncomfortable you know such
as hearing things that you didn't think
they could hear like in my head you know
super super hearing I could hear a
conversation all the way down that
hallway and somebody said something
about me and I ran out there is it hey
what are you talking about that would
make people uncomfortable no there and
then now that I kind of trusted one that
could really undermine people embracing
this technology and creating the kind of
trust for human interaction really going
for you same thing with vision you know
if you had leg up you know 100 X camera
on this thing you might have the same
kind of so we need to be really careful
about that now I've mentioned a couple
ways where we do think it's better than
being there and we're trying to do that
in ways that doesn't that dope that
don't also make people uncomfortable oh
well one other thing about intervention
is kind of funny is that you can race
people right so we have a really long
building have long and thin we have we
have used at each end so if i have a
meeting at one end of the building and
then I need to talk to some people at
the other end they're going to walk over
there and I can be there instantly and I
say hey what took you guys so long and
you know that kind of stuff is that's
definitely a benefit because you can
move around I mean you can actually go
around the world like in the video you
can instantly teleport you know anywhere
you need to be but that's one word I
don't see that there's much risk of of
making people uncomfortable by
the fact that you can do a bit we need
to pay attention let's see okay so as
you could probably tell oh sorry yes
question oh I just curious um when you
when you're just sort of hanging out
together to sort of be there but you're
working say coding or whatever in it do
people adopt any sort of practice on how
they signaled up to locals they don't
have a desk that they sit down that so
obviously not my desk working there at
their desk working no matter where they
are highlighting the device today yeah
that's a good question and that's
something that also we need to
understand more to translate to what
customers are doing because it's
suitable we do have desks so basically
everyone who's there or in a beam has a
desk as desk space and so what you do is
if you're not you know you're not
actively doing and you're just sort of
working passively as we call it what we
tend to do is we just drive over to our
desk is turn face out so people can see
were there and then now we come over to
talk to somebody doesn't matter if
they're there physically in person or
after they're in a beam you know where
you can go find them to target and that
works really well for us well as I was
saying we're not seeing as many of our
customers do that and maybe it's because
the people one of the reasons might be
that the people who are going to be
using the technology don't have an
equivalent space where they can just
hang out and I don't know what we do
about that maybe they need to invest in
the space or maybe we need to find some
other way to signal that you want to
communicate with those people does that
listen up is right so yeah so we went
from the scenario where we were local
and we wanted to sort of learn what it's
like to remotely act like a remote but
if you're coming from the yeah yeah so
this is exactly the kind of stuff that
we need to figure out yes right right so
you need you don't necessarily need a
full office all you need is like a 2 by
2 square but then if you're putting
somebody in a 2 by 2 square are they
going to feel weird about that right
it's kind of you know you know with
Michael lined up in the generators you
could but you know I don't know people
feel comfortable be seen that way you
know just be one in the line of
music the questions uh yes I anyway i
thought i was going to wrap things up
with some of the interesting areas for
research when we've already talked a lot
about about a lot of interesting
questions but some areas of research
done that we're currently exploring and
some others you know where other people
wanted to get involved these are some
some of the interesting questions that
we see so the pilots want to do they
want to have more credit they want to do
things like carry things around do the
nonverbal communication one pilot
mentioned wanting to be able to which
what I thought Carrie was doing
correctly you know get attention without
speaking you don't be able to raise a
hand or few things like nodding passive
agreement that kind of stuff so how can
we do that keeping in mind the cost of
adding you know more degrees a prenup
advice now what we're really successful
as an industry and there are lots of
remote presence devices all around the
world and what did they start out number
locally we've talked about some of the
challenges of that we need to figure out
how to improve this for locals because
right now there are some garrisoned draw
back so we really need to figure out how
to make it something that people are
more comfortable with and we also talked
about how to be allowed for example but
you know a bigger question is what is
the work we were just what what is the
workplace of the future look like when
this is a common option like when this
is an option for for many if not most
people how does it change the way we
design offices how does it change the
way we design the home interior design
architecture community spaces you know
if you can visit a museum with a remote
presence device how would you redesign a
museum I think these are all really
interesting questions and it's maybe
it's you know too little early to be
redesigning museums all over the world
for this but the technology is coming
and it probably release merits some
thought there's an interesting question
of when is the appropriate time to
transition to another medium so we see
that this happens all the time in our
office and it sometimes it'll just turn
into a skype call to say hey let's just
take this offline it's okay well offline
meaning not in a beam but then others
can't over here so there's actually a
lot of benefit for having this
conversation out in the open we have an
open floor plan like many offices so
other people can can't I min or
contribute if they're interested
but we still use all the other sort of
back you know we use IM chat email and
everything to what when's the right time
how seamless do you want to make that
that's it i think that's a really
interesting question here's a here's a
meeting i recently attended sorry for
the quality of the photo but i'll
explain that in a second so we were all
four of us were remote as you can see
but we decided to stay that way because
we were expecting a fifth person to come
in person but what he rolled in in a
beam as well then we said hey forget it
we'll just switch to a hangout so but
but the other thing i was going to point
out is the reason that the picture the
quality is so bad as it's washed out
because the lights are off and that's
because there are no humans there so you
know you have all these funny situations
that kind of right because we're taking
an advantage of the fact that we have
this technology but there are some very
basic things that we're still not able
to to handle and i also wanted to
mention some of the opportunities with
crowd work which is developed you know
along with the internet as a way of
quickly assembling a large number of
people to work on something and and
professor Bernstein Research for example
shows that one way to really improve
crowd work is through better
communication I think it's interesting
to think about what happens if you
combine remote presence with something
like mechanical turk right so now the
tasks can be done not just by somebody
with a computer and the internet but
what if you give them a physical
presence as well what kind of tasks how
do you manage that you know i mean i can
only the possibilities really seem
almost limitless and if you look at some
of the some of the new services that are
popping up like TaskRabbit and exact as
ways of applying crowd work to in purse
and tasks you know such as delivery or
cleaning seem to be a couple the most
successful so far robo robo presents can
actually extend that capability quite a
bit by allowing you to do these kind of
in-person tasks almost anywhere and by
anyone this pieces of research had
people driving around robots and not
rule out in this case and what they
found is you were taking boats n sit as
a tree straight ahead of you have people
say oh right
take the left you have a nice drive
straight into it see you happy real time
cool this is what they end up doing
elect a leader to sort of temporarily
sort of round robin around but it's not
clear you know if you had some people
controlling my arms and other people
controlling where I'm moving could you
actually make it feel like a single
individual penalty kurz onto the first
remote presents flash mob yeah for
example i vos easy just pleasure to see
me rolling into his face and starting to
sing I mean we can contrive usage but we
really want to see what it happened
organically for a reason that now will
be relieved sigh see how something a lot
about and then finally I find this is a
really interesting question to me where
people live at work again when this
becomes up the more common option so for
example will bay area real estate supper
okay real premium to live in San
Francisco or silicon valley so what if
you're able to really effectively d
couple where you live from where you
work I don't know that's a big question
but one thing I do know is these are two
places that a suitable employee has
lived since we built beam we had a guy
who was living in San Francisco he said
you know what I'm tired of paying this
rent I don't have to live here anymore
I'm moving to Maui and it didn't change
his job at all he works with us the
exact same way he did before and then
winter came around he said no I want to
go to Lake Tahoe and he could do that
now it gets a little more complicated
when your family and stuff but you know
I'm I'm kind of envious of these young
guys they could just they can live
wherever they want now and and so when
when this becomes when this becomes an
option for a lot of people what does
that do to where people choose to live
in the societies that that are there I
mean I don't know mmm with that I will
wrap it up um thank you for for
listening I'm happy to take any more
questions or
thanks we have we have a few minutes
andreea yeah first of all when you
showed the two pictures I I thought
people had themes in those places so
that so that I could sort of hang out on
the beach with that thing but what you
said that when they were this human
didn't show up the one that you have
expected right when you were there and
you yell and you use decide to switch to
hangout so why did you do that where was
it better than 0 because when there are
no humans there then most of the benefit
of having the device just for the
purposes of that meeting so it's
interesting what we do is we all
switched to a google hangout for the
meeting and then we all switch back to
to the to the remote presence devices
afterward and drive out again because
only for the for the for the limited
duration of that meeting there's not
much of a benefit because all we're
doing is looking at each other and
talking and sorry yeah well you know and
there are some there definitely some
improvements by switching to a hangout
so you know you probably have the video
and audio are going to be better because
it's not going you know like i said is
not going analog to digital twice you
know you're just going straight straight
from the camera and some of the nice you
know features of being able to
communicate non-verbally or informally
of the more rich interaction that you
have with people who are there and the
convenience of also having it for them
so notice also if you're a person who's
there and the other people in the
meeting or in remote presence devices
you didn't have to do anything to set up
that meeting you didn't have to like
answer a skype call turn on a computer
turn on the projector anything like that
you just SAT there and they rolled in so
that's very convenient for you but if
everyone's in this if everyone's remote
then it's not saving that work for
anybody and so the benefits of just
using a google hangout kind of outweigh
the benefits of staying in devices yes i
have offices and boxes right so we have
a meeting with one person each of these
five cities who
where that's an interesting question to
me worse we're exploring that with some
of our customers now I mean the honest
answer is we don't we don't know that's
not a that's not a one that we were able
to simulate with ourselves easily we
know we're only in one or two locations
ourselves I would anticipate that in
most cases there will still be a de
facto hub where most people are I mean
if it's truly one from five different
places then again remote presence might
not be the right thing because almost
everyone's going to be remote from
somewhere but my guess is in most
situations there will still be some
reason that one of the locations would
be a help either because of other
factors like other equipment that's in
the room or other things that they have
access to or just simply having more
people pretty much yes Oh does it
support screech it yes you can share no
an application or your desktop enjoy it
on that's not in our video because it
was added sweet okay yes oh you're how
you might change the design if you were
considering non office scenarios I like
bring grandma along to Disneyland or did
I leave the stove on at home when I left
for work do you think that this is not a
very different to well the solution
probably would not be the same I guess
that's the olden questions if you were
to swap you switch those bits we needed
to be the first things you think about
changing we get asked about this stuff
all the time I mean people see the demo
anything can we use it for this totally
different things I everyone so one thing
is it's really designed to be used
indoors we decided to be to navigate any
kind of compliance space so ramps floors
bumps etc that should be ok but once you
take it outside you've got things like
curbs and and animals and dirt milk it's
not so any kind of outdoor application
would probably require us to redesign
you know the mechanical system a fair
amount for use in things like one of the
most common things that people say is I
would love to put this in my parents
house almost everyone has ever seen this
thing whether they want to buy for their
company or not they say I would like to
put this in my pair of my mom my dad my
parents house so I can you know
to them more easily I can check on them
do the kind of thing you know make sure
that they're safe and nothing happened
but unfortunately at our current price
point most people don't consider that an
option so we certainly see an
opportunity there I don't know what what
the changes are to make that I mean
mostly it sounds like cost reduction so
what can we do to preserve the quality
of that experience but bring the price
down quite a bit I don't know if we if
we thought we could we would have done
it already I mean to make it as reliable
and high quality and really give you
that true remote presence you know we
did what we thought was an absolute
minimum actually so I guess that does
really answer your question but I think
each one of those scenarios would be
different and probably have different
needs that need to be and then there's
also the networking so one of the first
things we have to do any time we deploy
these into a new site is we have to make
sure that your Wi-Fi is really good or
4G we now have support for 4G coverage
but in many cases you know people think
that their Wi-Fi is really good but
there are little gaps here and there and
that's really important for us to find
out about so you know again to put it in
the home requires a level of service and
attention that you know we have to think
about yes we ninety-five percent and
homeless haha 100% intro servania how
the device failed when you guys were
doing only ones where did that five
percent come from yeah um it was a
hardware problem or network problem it
was a variety of things you know
unfortunately I wish it were just one
thing that we put a fixed it with a lot
easier it's probably about ten things
they need to contribute at a half
percent or something like that so we
were at that time we were using we're
using off-the-shelf video conferencing
we were using the well basically we were
using skype but a living soul because
the linux we have a linux computer on
the device and that one's not a reliable
and occasionally it just would fail to
connect a call that was really
frustrating because we didn't we didn't
know what to do about that and so we had
to read we basically we developed our
own video conferencing application from
the ground up just to solve that problem
in a couple of like it but that got us
over the hump on that one Wi-Fi
reliability so we've got I mentioned we
to dual band Wi-Fi radios because one
you know just isn't we have a really
actually quite sophisticated handoff
algorithm so one one's always acted in
one scanning for another network to
connect to so that there's really we
were able to prevent any gaps when
you're switching from one access point
to another point goes down that kind of
spin took a lot of engineering just a
variety of things like that mechanical
failures you know going through making
sure we had evaluate a lot of different
components for you know the motors
cameras and everything to make sure that
we got ones that we're really going to
be reliable and put all the component
verification procedures in place we
didn't go through all these steps when
we built the text i prototypes yes um
almost are a lot of the systems on the
robot redundant done or just like the
Wi-Fi oh I see Oh serious they know like
the Segway says one of the big things
this week oh yeah hang on there it's
duplicated i don't know if i would say
every if everything is redundant but we
certainly have a lot of things like
safety watch dogs and other safety
safety loops that are that are
constantly checking things so they're a
lot of redundant checks even within the
firmware and software sure mechanically
I wouldn't say that everything is
redundant but that's harder for me to
say what my role is I believe the
software team so yes if you looked into
any augmentation with autonomy as far as
I just go into the room go into the
corner we have looked into it as a
common question as it currently exists
being has no autonomy some of the other
remote presence devices by the way do
they'll do things like the automatically
got themselves or I forget what else
they can do simple stuff but a little
bit and we decided that it was more
important for us to focus on doing a
faithful what was sort of an important
to actually carry out the intentions of
the pilot as as faithfully as possible
and not so worry as much about we're
also concerned about safety so once you
get into this autonomous behavior you
know it's kind of that same 95% if it
upgrades safely ninety-five percent of
the time that
not anywhere near video so you have to
make sure you if you're going to add any
kind of those features that it's that
you can guarantee is never going to go
over a staircase or never going to and
so we call though it was more important
to make sure that what everything the
pilot is doing is exactly what the
device is going to do but we're
certainly thinking about it for the
future it's hard for me to say exactly
you know what what the product will be
doing in a year or two from now but
we've thought about a lot of things
you